Now, on to our first sight.
Tiananmen Square, named after the Tiananmen gate...
...to the Forbidden City to the north.
This is the world's fourth largest square.
It measures 440,000 square meters...
...and it's a great place to come and to just people-watch...
...and take in the humanity here.
The square is also home to several other important attractions...
...including the National Museum of China...
...and the daily flag raising and flag lowering ceremony...
...here, at the top of this flagpole.
If you want to see the flag raising,...
...you'll have to get up early because it happens before sunrise,...
...some days as early as 4:45 in the morning.
Next stop is the Forbidden City.
It was home to 24 emperors.
It is the world's largest palace complex and has over 8,000 rooms.
The main entrance is just to the north Tiananmen Square...
...underneath the portrait of Chairman Mao.
The palace got the name the Forbidden City...
...because in the past, no one was allowed to enter or leave...
...without the emperor's permission.
But today, you can enter for the low, low price of 60 renminbi.
Just make sure you get here before 4 o'clock to buy your ticket.